For clarity, a file system is
essentially the system by which
the permanent storage space
of a device is organized and
divided up to hold files.
The type of file system a machine has
is determined by the operating system
running on that machine.
For iPhones and iPads this
operating system is called iOS.
And similar to the operating
system running on Macs,
it dictates a UNIX based file system
made up of a hierarchy of directories.
With the primary goals of security and
simplicity in mind, the file system for
iOS was conceived with
the notion of treating all apps
as self-contained independent islands.
Each app when it's installed,
is placed in what's called a sandbox, or
self-contained area of the file system
in which to keep all of its stuff.
You can imagine a new app on your
device as a new student at a school.
Let's call her Appigail.
The new student is given a locker to
keep books, papers, personal items, and
whatever else.
The lockers locked so only this
student has access to her own things.
Likewise, the student doesn't have
access to any fellow student’s lockers.
The only thing is, imagine that
this is a magical school and
that the lockers maintain
magical properties.
There's an overall finite amount of
space that all the walkers combined can
take up, but until that space limit is
reached, each student's locker will
expand to fit whatever is put into it or
new lockers can be created.
Whereas if a student has
to store gym bag and
large textbooks, as long as the overall
locker system has extra space
this student's personal locker
will expand to fit his items.
Likewise, you,
the device's owner, get to decide
how you want the space allocated.
Whether you want to keep 12 gigabytes
of photos, and 6 gigs of music, and
6 gigs of small apps,
the choice is up to you.